it's crucial that we live
they've got the numbers we need the
patience
[Music]
wants you to make a mistake of course he
does what should I do differently I
don't know I don't know anything about
battles just just don't do what he wants
you to do
nice good advice you think that's
obvious well it is a bit obvious
hey guys Pete here get old John snow yep
we're picking up the problems with Game
of Thrones Season eight series today and
we're gonna talk about the king in the
north
John snow is he still the king in the
north now that he's pledged himself to
Daenerys I guess he probably no longer
carries that title anyway it's just a
reminder of what this series is all
about there are so many different ways
the ending of Game of Thrones can go I
decided to look at the problems with
specific plot lines so I'm not hating on
the show of course I've been
disappointed in the last couple seasons
with things that have happened but I'm
still a fan this isn't a thing about
like how I think Game of Thrones season
8 is gonna be terrible or why I think
the show is terrible I actually have
high hopes for the final season looking
at the problems with the different
stories just gives us a way to work
through what might actually happen at
the end Jon Snow has a lot of problems
he's a walking problem at the same time
he's awesome as we saw in that clip
there he has made some bad decisions in
the heat of battle that's just one
example of that happening I suppose that
is excusable in that it makes him
relatable I'm sure in your own life you
could think of a situation where you had
things all planned out and you were
gonna do it a certain way and then you
get caught up in the emotion of it all
and I'm sure on some level for some
viewers this really kind of makes him a
better character the first big problem
that Jon has as far as this series is
concerned though is that he is a hero we
like him he's got a tough story he
turned things around but that also makes
him kind of an archetypal hero character
that we've seen before he was born
thinking he was a bastard this causes
him to go on this journey he leaves home
comes a member of the Nights Watch his
mentor growing up Ned Stark who he
thinks is his father happens to die the
mentor that he gets at the wall Giora
Mormont ends up dying in the process of
that he gets himself a magical sword
none of these things come out as things
you haven't seen before the reason why
this is such a big problem is because we
don't expect this to have
stereotypical fantasy ending of the hero
triumphing over evil and winning and
sitting on the Iron Throne at the end to
rule his kingdom with his bride by his
side
you know it's just not what we're
expecting to have happen the story just
hits that hero character a little bit
too close he's had to overcome adversity
he had to make some tough decisions and
do what he knew was right and he even
got killed only to be resurrected as a
result of that how can you not like this
guy at the same time we don't want to
see him win we don't think that he'll
win because we've been watching the
story and we don't think that's how it's
gonna go I think it's important to say
though you know you hear people say a
lot like it's not gonna have a Disney
ending there's a reason why Disney
movies have the Disney ending there's a
reason why so many stories are a hero's
journey story it works it's a compelling
tale to tell so if you're sitting there
thinking well I think it would be great
if Jon Snow was on the Iron Throne at
the end of the story and Daenerys was by
his side and I'm not saying that that's
a stupid thing to want I'm just saying
that I don't think that's what's going
to happen some of the other problems
that I see with John's story is that one
he doesn't really seem like he would be
a good leader
to paraphrase george RR martin just
because someone is a good person doesn't
make them a good leader and we've kind
of seen that in this world most of the
people that we've seen in this world who
are good at playing the game of Thrones
also happen to be terrible people Tywin
Lannister Petyr Baelish Cersei is doing
a pretty good job of it right now you
get the idea Jon kind of fascist himself
after Ned Stark he tries to be an
honorable man he tries to do the right
thing and let's just remember what
happened in that Stark in this world for
a more recent example in season seven
when they were in the dragon pit Cersei
said she would commit her troops and of
course she may have been lying at that
point too but she said she would as long
as Jon wouldn't back either Queen in the
war that came after the war for the dawn
and all Jon had to do was just tell a
little lie instead he decided to tell
her the true
and as we all saw things broke down so I
think it's safe to say that if things
stayed the way that they are John isn't
really cut out to be a leader in the
world that we know another problem with
that is that he probably wouldn't want
to be one either you could actually
totally see John saying no if the throne
was offered to him at the end but I mean
we've all seen the story of the
reluctant hero - so I'd only think that
exactly evens things out but it is worth
noting that he probably wouldn't want to
rule and if there was any way to get out
of it he would probably take that option
instead another big problem with John is
that he has been reanimated or
resurrected or he was dead and now he's
alive there are some practical problems
related to that with the people except
someone who's reanimated as a leader
what if the magic all disappears will he
still be alive things like that but why
I bring this up as a problem with the
story is because we've already seen that
happen whether you saw it on the show or
you read it in the books when John died
the first time it was pretty unless
someone told you about it like he
weren't really expecting it it was a
shocker of course there were a few
people who had already come back from
the dead so at that point in the story
you're no longer thinking like he's for
sure dead dead but yeah we sort of went
through that once and would it really
have the same effect again I mean it
would it would it would be sad if he
died but we just it just doesn't seem
like the big twist in the show is that
John's gonna die for real since he's
still dead in the books we don't know a
whole lot about it you know the show
doesn't really go into the details very
deeply I believe it in the books you
know he where he has a connection with
ghost like an actual worgen connection
I've always assumed that he would go
into ghosts and then he'll come back you
know he'll be he'll probably still be
brought back by Melisandre but we'll
know a little bit more about the details
of his coming back because John and the
show doesn't seem a whole lot different
than he did before he died like the
other ones that we've seen come back in
the books like Marek
and then Lady Stoneheart there they're
clearly changed and that's a theme
that's always been running through the
story that you have to pay a price you
know you lose something in order for
that to happen Khal Drogo was a good
example of that I was under the
impression that John in the show is
exactly the same but the other day I was
listening to a podcast where Bryan
cogman was being interviewed and he
actually said that Kit Harington plays
John different now like there's a
noticeable difference at least that
Bryan cogman who is a writer turned
executive producer on the show as far as
he's concerned he sees the difference in
John I don't think it's very clear I
don't think they've gone out of the way
to make that clear to us that somehow
John has been changed by the experience
george RR martin had mentioned that
Barrack was sort of like a fire white
and that he loses something every time
he comes back but he's a FireWire in the
sense that he doesn't have blood moving
through his veins like he's not really
alive not in the sense that everyone
else is Catelyn is definitely not the
same as she was as Lady Stoneheart John
may end up being a different case
because if he goes into ghosts then
maybe he won't lose as much of himself
or whatever but we just don't know about
that and it was said that Barrack was
foreshadowing for John that being a fire
white but it doesn't mean that he will
be exactly the same it just meant that
we see people brought back to life in
this world so we know that it's possible
that John could come back to so in
relation to him being able to say father
a child with Daenerys or anything like
that I think that it's a pretty good
guess that he can but as far as the
story goes him dying a second time just
isn't as exciting as someone else dying
since we're on the topic of Daenerys it
should be said that he has a problem as
far as his new love affair is concerned
and I think it should be classified as a
love affair I think there's a real
connection that they have I don't think
it's some BS political John theory kind
of I think that their relationship will
be legit they'll have to deal with the
fact that they are related and that he
is not who he thought he was but it's
interesting because we talk about the
conflict in character
his conflict was always his identity
that shifted once he became the
spokesperson for the war against the
night king and the White Walkers that
became his identity he was the one who
needed to rally the troops and then he
met the dragon queen and now he is in
fact in love and then that's set up to
be a big part of his identity now is
that he found this person but it's
complicated
like I said in her video I think it'll
just play itself out though I think that
they have bigger things to worry about
in the first couple of episodes he'll
find out who his parents were who he
actually is but I don't think that that
will become his identity like I don't
think that Aegon Targaryen will be born
once he finds this out I think that as I
mentioned earlier he wouldn't want to be
a ruler if given the opportunity but he
will have to come to terms with that he
will have to work it out with his aunt
how things move forward with their
relationship his claim to the throne is
better than hers and and all of that
other stuff that we all know is gonna be
from the forefront of their
conversations for at least a couple
episodes I also mentioned in that other
video I think if it comes down to her
being with child there's no way that
he's going to allow another bastard to
be brought into the world so he's going
to have to work it out in his head until
he can justify it as the honorable thing
to do and it's just gonna work itself
out all of these things of course fit
into the last and the biggest problem in
my mind John is not a great leader he's
not the right kind of guy for this story
as far as being a leader he's way too
on-the-nose as being a hero character
his story is just the hero story he has
a tendency to make bad decisions in the
heat of the battle he doesn't want to
lead and of course he did die and came
back to life which means that his death
isn't that exciting so the final problem
turns out to be what do we do with Jon
Snow at the end of the story there are a
lot of different theories which I guess
I'll touch on a bit
I don't want to go down any of those
roads because I don't think ultimately
they're going to happen one Syria that's
out there amongst book readers is that
John is the target of the night King and
the reason that is the case is because
he needs John to take his place
I mean that's the really simplified
version of it but he doesn't want to
kill John he doesn't want to be the
night King anymore and he wants John to
take his place and there's a fairly
decent theory that makes sense if you
follow it all the way through another
theory is that the magic will have to
end at the end of the story
this would likely I'll get into this
more in my problems with bran video
that'll come out after this one but so
probably involve bran doing something
inside the weirwood Network that shuts
the whole thing down again this is very
simple simple telling of the theory that
kind of makes sense if you read it all
the way out in that situation is John
just brought back is he alive because of
magic does John then die whenever the
Magic's gone some people seem to think
that that's the case but I mean if he's
not going to be the big exciting death
in the season and if he's not going to
sit on the throne and rule as the king
what do we do with him does he just jump
on a dragon as he just jump on Ragle at
the end and fly off into the sunset and
agree never to come back I've heard
people say something along that lines
but I'd you know it's just kind of hard
to figure out isn't it the one thing
that I can say that you know as I've
been looking at all these different
stories there's an underlying idea that
there's gonna have to be a battle with
the knight king and the White Walkers
that isn't the final end of the story
it's gonna probably be followed up with
the fight for King's Landing that all
pretty much looks like a reasonable I
doubt line for the season but then we
have the situation after so in the
process of that right we have people are
going to there's gonna be a big death
and there's a lot of people are gonna
die and there's gonna be some kinds of
twist and you know something major is
gonna happen and the world is gonna come
out different on the other
and and where does Jon Snow fit in that
it's entirely possible that it has a
happy ending that it goes Disney right
that's not out of the realm of
possibilities it's entirely possible he
will die one way or the other somebody's
gonna have to sacrifice to make that
victory over the night king happen as I
mentioned in other videos I tend to
think that Daenerys is the one that's
gonna die but it could really go either
way between those two what would
actually be surprising is if they both
lived all the way to the end and there
is the possibility that they both die
that's definitely up there as well so my
big problem with Jon Snow is I just
can't figure out what his story ends up
being you know I just can't fit him into
a box that says this is the most fitting
ending for him and so I would love to
hear what you guys think let me know in
the comments let me know what problems
you see with Jon is the hero's quest I
mean the the story of the hero is that a
problem or are you with that
where do you think he'll end up what do
you want to see what are you hoping for
that you know that you'll never see let
me know what you think I'll have a
couple more of these coming out next
week so please check back if you want to
follow along you know what to do thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon